we viewed her as a mortal an essential
part of the fabric
of our world
there is of course an outpouring of
grief and
love across the globe she was
universally adored she represented good
in this world living a life of of honor
a life dedicated to service dedicated to
bettering the lives of others
well said james corden again on last
night's late late show adding his voice
to the millions remembering queen
elizabeth with great love and certainly
great respect we welcome you back to cbs
mornings we're also taking a look back
at the queen's very long and
distinguished reign longer than any
other british monarch it was not the
life that she or anybody else would have
expected when she was born
april 21st 1926.
mark phillips reported on many of the
milestones in her extraordinary life
he's outside buckingham palace with more
little nuggets that only mark phillips
can share mark i think about her life
that she knew when she was 10 years old
that one day she was going to be queen
it's extraordinary
good morning well yes indeed elizabeth
did not know when she was a child that
she was destined to be queen that
happened as a matter of some royal
accident which we'll get into but you
know it's always difficult to try to sum
up the public mood and these sorts of
things there is however no difficulty
this time there's a palpable sense of
sadness that is hanging over britain and
i suggest over much of the world the
initial shock may have worn off a little
bit but it's been replaced by a sense of
sadness sadness for the woman who is now
gone who led us through so much history
and who made so much of her own
for a woman who was not born to be queen
the public outpouring of affection for
elizabeth during the celebration of her
70th year on the throne was a tribute to
her and to how well she had done her job
elizabeth alexandra mary windsor queen
elizabeth ii reinvented the british
monarchy and may have saved it
elizabeth was already 10 years old when
another royal drama led to her becoming
heir to the throne in 1936 her uncle
edward viii abdicated to marry the
american divorcee wallace simpson and
the royal line shifted to her father
george vi and so to her
the young princess elizabeth was already
a public favorite i am sure that youth
are often thinking of their old country
during the second world war she had
worked to raise the country's morale to
make the world of tomorrow a better and
happier place
and she had also served as a volunteer
in the war effort her marriage to philip
mountbatten an anglicized member of the
deposed greek royal family gave a
war-weary country something to celebrate
and the children the marriage produced
first charles and then anne secured the
future
elizabeth's coronation in 1953 was the
first ever to be televised its
combination of ancient ceremony and
glittering glamour cemented her as the
personification of britain's post-war
rebirth
and it began a reign with a singular
purpose
i declare before you all
that my whole life
whether it be long or short shall be
devoted to your service
elizabeth's reign would be the longest
ever in a royal bloodline that goes back
over a thousand years but the royal ride
was sometimes bumpy the stability and
continuity the monarchy was supposed to
provide began to look shaky as one by
one the royal marriages broke down
around her her sister margaret's
her daughter anne's
her son andrews they all ended in
awkward divorces
none was uglier than the breakup of
prince charles and diana spencer
the long public unraveling of the
marriage of the heir to the throne
seemed to shake the very foundations of
the royal household
when in the early 1990s windsor castle
also went up in flames the queen's
famous stoicism was tested
1992
is not a year on which i shall look back
with undiluted pleasure
in the words of one of my more
sympathetic correspondence
it has turned out to be an anus or
rebellious
however horrible the year the windsor
castle fire and the public complaints
over the skyrocketing repair costs
produced a turning point in royal
history
monarchs normally collect taxes but from
then on the queen agreed to pay taxes on
her income
royal behavior was also changed by the
shocking death of diana in that paris
car crash
the national outpouring of grief seemed
to highlight the emotional gap between
the queen and her people
elizabeth did much to repair the damage
with a single bow of the head to the
passing coffin of a popular
princess there would be other challenges
one of the most serious centering around
the wife of one of diana's sons
when prince harry's biracial american
wife meghan markle complained of
mistreatment by palace officials the
couple renounced the royal life and
moved to california
when elizabeth's husband prince philip
died she was left alone but in a
decision some questioned she defiantly
chose her son andrew to escort her at
phillips memorial service even though he
had been disgraced by his association
with the sex trafficker jeffrey epstein
in seven decades on the throne elizabeth
redefined the monarchy remade it for a
more modern less deferential age
and in the process she became not just
the queen of great britain she became in
a way
queen of the world
the days are long gone when the monarchy
exercised hard political power here but
elizabeth invented something else soft
power influence she had plenty of that
and we'll now see just how much that is
missed
we are about to find out indeed
influence is definitely something that
she managed to cultivate in her long
reign mark phillips for us in london
mark thank you very much you know we've
been hearing that clip over and over
again which as a young woman she says i
dedicate my life to service whether it
be long or short later in that same
address she says but but she cannot do
it without the public support and boy
did she get it yeah three out of four
people in the uk
support her and approve of what she did
think about that i mean it's hard to
think of anybody or thing that has 75
approval rating and if for most people
they didn't know anybody other than
queen elizabeth ii that's why i marvel
at she really did embody that keep calm
and carry on under all circumstances as
mark phillips said reinvented the
monarchy and possibly even saved it yes
yes